immigration issues are likely to come up
with Democratic presidential candidates
debate for the very first time tonight
in Miami 20 candidates qualified for the
debates and we'll hear from ten more
we'll hear from ten this evening and
then ten more tomorrow at O'Keefe is in
Miami near the site of the event
Edie a lot of people are gonna be on
that stage what can we expect to hear we
can expect Tony that most of them are
gonna be trying to introduce themselves
for the first time to audiences that
don't know them this is the largest
debate ever of Democratic presidential
candidates and none of them should
expect much air time participants
tonight include senators Elizabeth
Warren Cory Booker and Amy Klobuchar as
well as New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio
former Texas congressman Beto O'Rourke
and former HUD secretary Julian Castro
now each have just 60 seconds to answer
questions 30 seconds for follow-ups
senators Kirsten Gillibrand and Pamela
Harris debate tomorrow night we caught
up with them recently to ask how they're
preparing do you even bother having like
nine of your staffers stand there on
stage with you and then try to debate
you is it worth even trying to rehearse
for something like that no for me it's
about making sure that I get used my
five or seven minutes whatever it ends
up being to share this vision and what
I'm gonna do and why I'm different
[Music]
and what makes for a good debate night
for Kabul Harris no mess-ups I gave you
in other words we've learned some of the
debate prep secrets of the candidates
senator Booker has been doing push-ups
during debate rehearsal breaks and has
been snacking on popcorn and on the
sparkling water of La Croix senator
Kamala Harris who got here on Monday has
been relying on a local staple of
Rosslyn poyo not chicken and rice maybe
the most interesting news to come out of
the debate no mess-ups Kamala Harris
motto I like that